the situation here in ukraine has the
attention of the world everyone is
looking for any sort of indication that
things are about to change american
officials announcing that they would be
removing non-essential
staff is seen as a slight shift in the
situation however american officials are
saying this move is just out of an
abundance of caution that they have no
new information suggesting that things
are about to change anytime soon as far
as canadians here at the embassy no
change for non-essential staff at least
not yet as far as canadians traveling it
is still recommended non-essential
travel should not happen given the
situation on the ground let's talk about
that situation for a little bit here
because it is incredibly serious the
pressure remains and there are fears
that that pressure between russia and
ukraine is going to snap at some point
right now we have hundreds of thousands
of russian troops and heavy equipment
poised right on the ukrainian border
ukrainian military officials and border
guards watching the russians trying to
make sure that there is no slight change
in their position again something that
would be another indication that things
are going to ratchet up today we did see
that nato has announced that they are
sending in more warships more fighter
jets to eastern europe they are
preparing and letting ukraine know that
they of course have the support of nato
and that they are ready to support
ukrainians should it come to that
situation so to start off the week a
little bit of a change but of course
everyone's watching to see if and when
things here may in fact escalate
crystal gomanson global news
keeve
[Music]